hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to the homeroom live
stream
uh a very exciting conversation today we
have mala sharma who is the vp and gm of
creative cloud at adobe but before we
jump into that conversation i will give
some of our standard announcements first
a reminder that khan academy is a
not-for-profit organization we can only
exist through donations from folks like
yourself so if you're in a position to
do so please think about making a
donation at khan academy.org donate i
also want to give a special shout out to
several organizations that stepped up
during the pandemic when they realized
that we were running at a big bigger
deficit than normal because of all the
server costs and our desire to
accelerate content to support
tens of millions of learners around the
world so special thanks to bank of
america t google.org novartis fastly and
general motors i also want to give a
special shout out to adobe this is a new
thing that we are announcing right now
and one of the reasons why mala is here
amongst many others
as our creativity partner and we're
going to be talking a lot more about
just education and the role that
creativity has to play and how khan
academy and adobe hope to work together
to really push the envelope there and
last but not least we want to remind
everyone that there's a version of this
that you can get wherever you get your
your podcast
homeroom with sal the podcast
so with that i'm excited to introduce
mala sharma vp and gm of adobe creative
cloud mala great to see you
it's great to see you too sal thank you
so much for having me here
well there's a ton of stuff i want to
talk to you about ask you about i know
you care deeply about education it's
teacher appreciation week i want to
learn about your journey and of course i
want to talk about what we are now going
to be doing together adobe and khan
academy but maybe a good place to start
just for people to understand context
what is the adobe creative cloud and
what does the vp and general manager of
adobe creative cloud do
so adobe creative cloud is the
creativity platform um that anybody can
use who has an idea to put out there in
the world we have professionals who use
it we have students we have consumers
like you and i
who have an idea and want to have impact
in the world it has
applications like photoshop premiere pro
indesign illustrator
applications that work on the desktop on
your mobile phone on the web adobe spark
is a part of creative cloud that is a a
web-based application
and not only does it have applications
it also has services integrated so you
can collaborate on creative cloud you
have content you can use you have
templates
um you have fonts that you can bring
into your creation so think about
anything you need to express an idea
is available within creative cloud and
what i do at adobe i have the privilege
of
managing the product marketing
organization
and the education business so i'm
responsible for thinking about how do we
get our products
more available
to our customers how do we grow the
business how do we make them more
accessible
to users wherever they are any part of
the world
any platform that they are on
and i work with product teams
engineering teams marketing teams
uh to get the product out there and
available to our customers
yeah and i've i've always i've had a
long relationship with many of those
product products i i use them now but i
you know all the way back i think it was
as early as 1991 or 1992 when i was the
art editor and layout editor for our
school newspaper in new orleans
under miss kennedy who is one of the
teachers that i always make a point of
appreciating during teacher appreciation
week she was our journalism and our
english teacher um
but that's when i first used what was
now part of the adobe creative cloud but
i used uh all of the the various the
various things in adobe suite you know
i'm curious how how do y'all how do you
and how does adobe
you know there's a lot of areas where
adobe is used obviously a lot of
designers creative professionals etc etc
what is the lens that you all take on on
education and and education in the
context of supporting teachers
especially
yeah there's uh education is very
important from a couple of perspectives
uh first of all
uh we believe that all of us as humans
are innately creative
and giving everybody a voice is an
important part of building self-worth
uh building uh great citizens in the
world
and therefore education is a conduit is
a very important vertical for us to get
students access to our products so that
they can tell their stories
and we have
in so many
infinite examples of where students when
they're able to put these stories
together put a voice to their ideas what
it does to their self-confidence and
what it does to to student outcomes
specifically so a big part of our focus
is
getting the products in the hands of
these students making them
work on platforms that students are on
whether they're on the web whether
they're on mobile devices or they're in
the lab working in
you know working in the lab so it's
about making the products work here in
these different places making it
affordable for schools adobe spark is
free for students to use
uh creative cloud which is over six
hundred dollars a month excuse me a year
product is just five dollars a year the
student in k-12 so really it's about
making the products work as well as
making them accessible through pricing
but the second area sal is about the
teachers and again it's great to be here
with you during teacher appreciation
week announcing this partnership because
teachers are where it makes way this all
happens they are the ones who sort of
you know um
help lead the students through the
learning process and making
them uh uh ready to bring creativity
into the classroom is another really
important piece of what adobe does we
have a platform called adobe education
exchange there's over a million teachers
on that platform they're sharing ideas
with each other there's project plans
there's lesson plans available for them
or how they can bring creativity into a
math class or into a science class or a
geography class
because what that does is
one it makes learning more interesting
it engages students but most importantly
the teachers can assess what the student
has actually comprehended and learned
through what they create
so
education to us is about making both of
those things possible which is
putting the
products in the hands of the students
and preparing the teachers to teach
creativity and bring creativity into the
classroom
and i definitely want to talk a lot more
about this especially what both adobe
and khan academy hope to do together but
before we go there i do want to focus a
little bit on
your story that's one of the interesting
things about about these conversations i
always love to learn how people
got to where they're going we have a lot
of young people who are watching this a
lot of parents were watching this
so so when you were young in elementary
school middle school did you say i mama
sharma i'm going to be a vp and gm of
adobe creative cloud what did you think
you were going to do
maybe it was that oh my gosh well if you
ask my mom she probably thought i was up
to no good
um i was a very very naughty student
and um
was always you know the person was
trying to distract the teacher in the
classroom and distract uh the students
in the classroom
uh but no i certainly had been curious
i'm sorry
you remember what you did
oh my gosh um
i don't know if the parents and teachers
would appreciate this
but i i used to be the student who would
sit at the back of the classroom and
you know um
throw little aeroplanes this is what we
did in india we made aeroplanes with you
know paper and we threw it uh out in
front of the classrooms i would chew
chalk and then you know throw chalk at
different students that was really bad
no chalk
that's a new one i did not know that
that's the thing that
oh my god yes i was a very naughty
but at some point um
sorry
no no go ahead now i'm going to say you
know but it clearly you you evolved uh
you you're going to say it but at some
point
please keep going
yes at some point um
i think i i realized that uh
it was important for me to pay attention
to learning and um and i think my mother
being a schoolteacher was part of that
um
and
really i think the
the way i'd sum it up
sal it's
it's um
a sequence of events that i didn't
expect would happen
but happened but i think the learning
that i had from my teachers from my
parents from the elders around me
was to be ready to embrace them
and be prepared for them
and be able to um uh you know uh not
just embrace them from the standpoint of
accept what happened but embrace them
and take them forward um you know
there there's been lots of ups and downs
in my um journey to get to here but
what's been consistent is being
confident
having a deep sense of self-worth
and a deep sense of confidence that if
somebody
presents something to me i can embrace
it and i think that comes from the
learning the learning and the teachers
around me and um
all the examples that were around me
that gave me that confidence
yeah so so i mean going back to your
original exam i mean your mother was a
teacher and you still it sounds like at
a young age or maybe not the most
obedient obedient child uh at least in
the in the classroom
do you remember when it kind of clicked
in you was there's particular moment
clearly your mother is a teacher who
played a big role in your life if we're
thinking about teacher appreciation week
but were there moments in your education
where you started saying wow this is
really interesting i'm not passionate
about this or this person is really
invested in me
yeah i think where um
what my mom did for us was it was not
just about what we learned in the
classroom
but she also encouraged us to do uh you
know
different kinds of learning so she put
us into theater
uh i was learning i was on stage at an
early stage i was learning
indian classical music
i was learning a rowing
and a variety of different experiences
that taught me consistently that when i
practiced and when i learned from people
who knew more than me
and who were better than me and i
observed what they did
that i was able to incorporate that
learning into whatever that i was
practicing and i think it was the
extracurricular activities
um and the interest that those teachers
and those mentors
took in me that helped me get better and
i was able to apply that into
uh into the classroom as well
and i think from a teacher's standpoint
when it came to you know just regular
studies um
it was a biology teacher who i had and i
think seventh grade she really made
learning incredibly interesting and this
is again you know many many years back
in india in a government school
uh where i was learning and we had the
resources were limited but the teacher
made it interesting by making us you
know take walks helping helping students
get together in groups and have
conversations about the different plants
we saw the different uh insects we saw
uh you know
bringing art by having us draw what we
were seeing and i think all of that and
the interest that she took in making it
fun and
uh making it non-monotonous and
surprising is what engaged me and helped
me
get more um interested in learning and
and then when i started seeing the
results of what i was doing uh i think
you know got me more serious about
continuing to do my studies
and i'm always curious because you know
when i remember when i was in especially
in high school and even in college you
see people whose careers their
mid-career or they've kind of gotten to
impressive places you're like what is
the path how did they figure that out
that they knew what they know what they
were doing i clearly didn't know what i
was doing
but when what did you think you were
going to do when did you kind of find
your direction did you know you're going
to go into industry going to marketing
did you think you were going to do
something else and when did you figure
that out
yeah so uh when i was in school as i
said i was in theater uh my first uh
dream was to um
actually take acting professionally and
i was in uh theater through school
through college
but then my parents didn't think that
was a good choice
my next choice was to join the indian
navy
because my father was um he's he's a war
hero and i really admired him and i was
like i want to go you know
represent my country and be patriotic
but he then discouraged me from doing
that because at that time women didn't
get great opportunities in the indian
navy you were typically stuck behind a
desk
as opposed to what i wanted to do was be
on the front
so that that's what i wanted to do um
and uh when neither of those worked out
at that time at my age or my batch at
the time everybody was studying to go
abroad
and um and i was like no i don't want to
go abroad i want to you know work for my
country
and i decided to do my masters in
business um because i didn't want to do
science because it looked like science
was too hard and people studied too much
so i kind of made the choices out of
convenience really and ended up doing my
mba
and then after that life just happened
you know i was i think
i think ultimately uh sal
if i were to look back on
what's consistent is
what you learn not just in school
but what values get instilled in you
and i think what's helped me through and
sort of guided me through uh
all the
ups and downs and i've had plenty of
downs as well
um is uh
really sort of hanging on to the values
that matter
and uh and for me it's about doing
what's right uh not what's good
it's about being
consistent and thoughtword in action
and it's those kinds of values that see
you through and i think it's so
important again teachers parents
play such an important role in not just
teaching us
the studies that we'd have to do but
also demonstrating and being the
examples for us when it comes to values
you know i'm curious you know i did not
know this background of yours that you
are essentially the theater kid turned
your corporate leader um
you know it's funny a lot of folks
when i was in college i took a theater
class just on a whim
just thinking it would be a nice change
of pace and i i thought it was
transformational and when i really think
about it it affects how i even
interact with people how i communicate
how aware i am of my own being
yeah
what was the effect of theater and
obviously we're here to talk about
creativity there's a lot of creativity
in theater how is that background i
think given you given you some some some
superpowers in it you know most of the
folks who are corporate leaders in
silicon valley
especially if our stereotypically say
you know coming from south asia they
were probably engineering majors you
know come out here start their life as a
software engineer and then move up
through management but you have a very
very different background how does that
either help to hurt you
i think the way it's helped me primarily
this a couple of things that come to
mind
one is the recognition that you are you
know you alone are not what makes that
play happen
there's you there's a person who pulls
the curtain there's the light there's
you know there's the person behind the
camera
there's a team that's involved and
everybody has to work in um in
in sync
uh it's the production is great uh for
the audience only when everybody is
operating together
um on time on cue
and all of that takes an incredible
amount of practice
and incredible amount of collaboration
um and incredible clarity on what the
outcome of the play needs to be
and that's what work is about
the second thing that i learned is
improvisation because oftentimes the
person you are you know working with
they or your excuse me who you might be
interacting with they might forget their
dialogue you might forget your dialogue
and being able to in the moment uh you
know sort of fill the gaps and let the
story continue
and the third area i think is just the
confidence right of um
being in front of
an audience and that's what business is
about
business is about collaboration it's
about
innovating it's about creative ideas
and it's about selling those ideas
confidently
through
storytelling and so i do think that it's
been something that's helped me
including my fighter spirit
right is that's where risk-taking and
planning um i think was an important
thing
that i really admired about the about
what my dad did
and that's something i found i've
incorporated into my work which is
really being thoughtful about
what the strategy for winning needs to
be
what the operational efficiency and
operational cadence needs to be
all of those
skills that you need in business
yeah you know i've never i've never made
the connection before but hearing you
describe it you're so right i never you
know i feel like theater should be part
of any business program now because
you're absolutely right it's a clear
goal a lot of coordination but as soon
as you're out there some new stuff might
happen you're going to have to improvise
uh and you know it reminds me i actually
was for half a year on in in college on
the uh improv comedy troupe and we used
to have to go to college
and you know you just go on stage with
no planning and you know people throw
out words and scenarios and i have never
gone through more stressful thing in my
life than being on an
improv comedy team but it also just you
know once you go through that you're
like well
nothing else in life's gonna surprise me
but but i never i'd never fully drawn
the prowls i'm gonna make sure my kids
get a little bit more more drama um
organized drama i think i'm already
providing some unorganized drama for
them uh but organized
in their in their lives
well let's listen gears a little bit
talk let's let's talk about this
partnership and obviously i have i'm
very excited about it but i'd love to
hear from your point of view
what excites you well you know i'd love
to hear your own words what your partner
what's the motivation for partnering
with khan academy and what do you hope
uh we're able to do together
yeah so this is an amazing opportunity
and sal we are so proud and honored to
be the creativity partner for
uh khan academy as i said earlier for
adobe
enabling creativity for everyone is our
mission
we believe every human is innately
creative and giving them a voice is a
part of our mission and the fact that
you know your platform serves
uh many millions i i believe it's over
100 million students
globally and the focus of your work has
been on in the stem area
what i'm excited about what adobe is
excited about is giving all of these
kids
through the classroom access to tools
where they can express themselves
creatively because what we've seen
happen sal and there's many many
examples including
a personal example i had when i was
volunteering in india would teach for
india where kids who'd never seen
technology had never interact with adobe
tools
when they were given access to this what
it changed for them in terms of not just
the learning experience
but what it did
for
them
in confidence is what we are excited
about and it's not just sort of the
uh the uh the storytelling aspect of it
we know
that future hiring managers
uh they value creativity in employees we
know we know that the world economic
forum bloomberg linkedin
their research has said that creativity
is a skill that most hiring managers are
looking for so the ramifications of
bringing creativity to your platform and
the lives that can impact is incredibly
thrilling and so important especially
in today's time where kids are you know
their entire education experience has
been upended uh because of covet
no i i couldn't agree with you more you
know from my point of view
when we khan academy's mission as a
not-for-profit is free world-class
education for anyone anywhere and
education has a lot of dimensions to it
there's the cognitive element of it
there's a socialization element of it
there's the credentialing side of it but
even if you talk about the cognitive
side of it a lot of folks listening know
bloom's cognitive taxonomy
it's usually drawn as a pyramid where
the base is remembering it's the most
wrote type of work to do then you go
into skills procedures and then as you
get to higher higher up the pyramid
you're getting into synthesis
application at the very top is create
and
you know i'm a big believer that you
need the whole pyramid uh that you know
if you just do one part without the
other you're selling yourself short but
the reason why i believe bloom set it up
as a pyramid is that they do to many
degrees build on each other not always
but many times build and khan academy
has historically focused on i would say
that that core foundational piece of the
pyramid more of the skill fluency the
etc but there's always a desire well for
real education we got to make sure kids
get the top of the pyramid as well and
so for us to be able to be so
complimentary where the students and
teachers who are already leveraging khan
academy and hopefully many more to
make sure they have fluency in their
mathematics and their sciences um have
that content knowledge also have
world-class tools to apply that in in
really thoughtful ways and that they
complement each other so you know this
is this announcement we're making this
week is very exciting and actually i'll
cue this video that uh i think we've put
together that describes the program and
we i think we can we can comment on it
as it's playing as well
teach creativity with adobe and khan
academy a powerful new partnership
bringing together creative tools and
content knowledge to empower thousands
of teachers and millions of students
worldwide it's a beautiful blend of
informative and engaging content get
started today by registering for our
brand new self-paced course available
for free on the adobe education exchange
take this course and earn up to 20 hours
of professional development credit and
maybe even a visit from sal khan himself
founder of khan academy register by may
17 and share a tweet tagging an educator
who inspires you with the hashtag
adobecon creativity for the chance to
win an adobe creativity kit want to
surprise your students with the voice
khan academy is best known for
yes we are talking about a virtual visit
to your classroom from sal khan should
you do that now you have or plan to
include creativity
submit your entry by may 17th and you
could win one of five virtual classroom
visits from sal khan embrace creativity
in powerful new ways with adobe and khan
academy sign up to the course and learn
how to get started now
i i hope it's an incentive
for people
their classrooms to be disrupted by me
so much fun the so the course that we've
designed it's specifically designed for
uh
khan teachers we
built built this along with your team
sal
and the courses are specifically
designed to be used like creativity and
math creativity and social studies
creativity and science
um and you know i i know recently um
there's a young woman called hillary
andalus who was part of your um i think
it's called the junior
junior uh breakthrough challenge yeah
yeah thank you
uh
and uh she's somebody adobe uh is very
familiar with uh when we got to know her
a few years ago when she was in her
teens
and as you know she is you know a stem
enthusiast
and uh she uh had a a classmate who was
very creative and she decided as a as a
young teen that you know why can't i be
creative
and she started teaching herself
photoshop and illustrator just for fun
and unfortunately while she was a little
kid
she lived in philippines there was this
really big typhoon that hit philippines
in her town it's called typhoon yolanda
and many people lost their lives and
there was a lot of damage
and what she realized that the
communication that was put together to
help people understand what the impact
of the typhoon would be was just not
impactful enough and that's when she
made a commitment to herself and has
done some amazing work to
really
take science concepts and make them more
accessible and understandable through
creative communication and she's done
this amazing work created this amazing
video and then of course she uh you know
got awarded the prize to the exact
challenge number is this oh she goes
yeah she says it's six
she says it's nine so
yeah i know
hillary's quite impressive
amazing woman and now she's an mit
thanks to the scholarship she got
and um
i think we can stop the video
yeah she is so inspiring but this is a
great example and i hope that the
teachers on your platform
can you know
take advantage of these lessons plans
there's hundreds of lessons plans
there's projects there's tests
that they can be bringing into the
classroom to inspire these kids to
communicate and tell these stories in an
impactful way making these concepts that
can sometimes seem obtuse
more accessible and have an impact
no hillary hillary's great i mean all
the breakthrough junior challenge
winners uh it's a very impressive uh a
set of you know they get 250 000 for
college they get
their teacher gets 50 000
uh and then they get a i think a 50 or
100 000
science lab for the school it's done by
the breakthrough prizes and it's really
a brainchild of yuri milner and several
other uh folks out here in silicon
valley but yeah it's incredible i'm i
i'm privileged to be part of the process
as one of the judges and obviously we
get the word out to the to the broader
khan academy community but but yeah
and to your point
hillary shows that
you know a lot of people think somehow
that that stem and creativity don't go
together in fact it's the exact opposite
i always say
you know the the factoring of polynomial
is is those are giving you the toolkit
so that you can unlock your creativity
in stem that isn't that that's like
saying that learning to mix paint is
painting no that unlocks your capability
to then become a painter and you see
someone like hillary
uh shows that in spades and shows the
importance of this type of work
absolutely absolutely
i'm super excited about uh what your
teachers can make possible for for the
kids
yeah well you know mala all these
conversations go much faster than i ever
i ever expect time flies when you're
having fun but you know i i just wanted
to first of all thank you uh for sharing
your story with us thank you for this
partnership between adobe and khan
academy i really do think it's going to
unlock
hopefully many millions of hillary and
dollars around the world uh to to
benefit all of us uh and and be just
more creative in the world which i think
just makes the world more interesting
any final thoughts for all of the the
parents and students and teachers
listening
i would just say um
[Music]
let your kids express themselves um in
the way that they want to
and know that the tools are just a means
to get their ideas out
and um creativity is equally important
as the science and the math that they're
learning
because that ultimately is how they will
be able to have impact is by bringing
their ideas
out into the world sharing them with
others um and having impact so thank you
love that thank you so much mala and i
couldn't agree with you more if you
don't have that creativity side then
really all of the the the skill level is
is to some degree all for not like it's
all it everything it needs to be in
service to creativity and we're so
excited about this partnership thank you
so much
thank you thank you it's a pleasure
and thanks for having me
no no it's been a pleasure thanks
everyone for for joining today we're
very excited about this partnership with
khan academy and adobe around creativity
uh parents students teachers you can all
check out the site that we're doing on
the creativity create creativity cloud
i'm sure if you do a google search uh
for khan academy adobe and the creative
cloud i'm sure you will find
all of these resources and we look
forward to go continuing to go on this
journey of learning with you thanks
everyone
you